[Music]
well learning for kids involves a whole
lot of technology and a whole lot of
time vulnerable to dangerous people
online so let's break down what ccsd is
doing to cut down on that risk
school kids today use computers
chromebooks tablets and technology to
learn and steps are taken to keep them
safe online
ccsd students are allowed internet
access but they sign a digital waiver
agreeing to use school technology for
school work the district also uses
programs to filter content are all
embedded with two different technologies
there's go guardian and then there's
also beacon go guardian software helps
schools manage student devices and then
those monitor they're not spying on the
kids they don't activate the cameras you
know when people don't want the cameras
on what they do is it monitors what the
kids do beacon is a tool that allows
administrators to track and report on
student interventions and if needed it
can turn a computer off even though they
might act mature they might might be on
their game with grades they're still
kids in the case of more extreme
behavior these technologies can help get
ahead of a crisis if a student types
something alarming where can i buy a gun
it'll send an alert to the school who
then alert the proper authorities the
school's action plan would then kick
into high gear it may end up that you
get a knock on your door with you know
local law enforcement school police or
any of our partners in the valley making
sure that everything's okay